o top quatro usando belga debates rádio
que dá like Box galera por aqui no box
Road início ao lado dos pessoal de quem
fala é o Dark sejam muito bem vindos a
mais um vídeo e como vocês puderam ler
pelo título sim pessoal sim eu cometi a
loucura eu gastei as minhas poupanças
todas para comprar iPhone 12 pro Maxx
que custam o equivalente a duas casas da
piscina e dos Jardins caro mas vai valer
a pena pessoal eu comprei este iPhone 12
vocês não leram errado ok eu comprei
precisamente para jogar free Fire depois
de muito tempo sem jogar free Fire eu já
tinha desinstalado há imenso tempo Volta
instalar a um mês atrás e em duas
semanas eu consegui pegar mestre mas eu
estava jogando no meu tablet e conseguir
pegar o mestre em duas semanas eu não eu
não sei se isso é muito bom ou não não
sei mas com o tablet eu não consigo
subir o famoso capa eu só do peito e
para quem costuma jogar sabe o quão
importante é o capa dar aquele 3K
Olá pessoal trouxe muito difícil de
jogar aqui então eu fiz um investimento
Ok eu fui comprar o iPhone dos para o
Max para ver se finalmente eu consigo
subir o capa e esse consigo jogar a
melhor e eu sei que muitos de Vocês
jogam com o telefone muito inferior
mesmo jogam com aquilo Alcatel dos anos
2000 e conseguem jogar muito bem eu sei
que há muita gente também que não tem
possibilidade de ter um iPhone e mesmo
assim consegue jogar um frito meu é
incrível vocês são incríveis agora eu
gosto dedão aqui dos que eu não queria
conseguir jogar sei lá assim no Android
à toa eu tenho que comprar um telefone
com uma tela enorme Stephanie para o Max
meu Olha aí se a tela for como está aqui
na caixa Sabe aquele cabelo estiloso
obviamente pessoal que eu não comprei só
para jogar o free Fire não é obviamente
que isso também vai servir para meu uso
pessoal mas de qualquer das formas
pessoal A intenção deste vídeo
experimentar o free Fire aqui vamos ver
se funciona vamos ver se Roda Bem com
certeza tem que levar porque isto é um
telefone da última geração tem que rodar
obviamente mas eu não sei se vou
conseguir subir o capu aqui então
experimentar hoje e já está bem pessoal
deixa
o like aqui nesse vídeo mesmo que não
joguem free Fire mesmo que Não gostem do
jogo Pessoal esse apoio muita que o
canal mesmo Ative o Sininho também olha
lá ó vou abrir aqui o iPhone é
impossível dizer que isso não é bonito
olha só essa gostosura ok pessoal
obviamente que isso não tá novo né
porque eu já usei eu comprei semana
passada já tenho um joguinho instalado e
tudo ela ajudar o free Fire pessoal Olha
aí tá rodar um
E chegou a hora só isso alguém aí at
Maloka comenta embaixo eu sou meio
militar devido ao tato é o mais potente
do jogo e bora lá pessoal já estamos
aqui dentro do free Fire a primeira
Recebi um convite calma calma calma a
primeira vista pessoal o jogo está a
rodar perfeitamente ó tá muito cliente
não convida por favor eu estou a gravar
Calma calma jogo com vocês ok pessoal o
jogo tá ajudar muito Clínico tua
diamante 1 no Battle Royale estou é
mestre no CS ranqueado eu consegui pegar
Este mestre com três semanas a jogar no
tablet mas aí está com o tablet não
consigo subir o capa Então já está muito
difícil de passar que o Mestre está
mesmo muito complicado então agora lá
ver se com esse iPhone pessoal eu vou
conseguir subir o nosso rank aí outra
coisa pessoal eu já testei esta iPhone
no Alecrim que eu fiz no canal de jogos
Dark frame 2.0 eu já fiz uma Leite de
Lima de estar mas ele não tinha as
configurações bem ou não tinha essa
sensibilidade correta tanto que eu aqui
configure algumas coisas com base nos
próprios
e eu tive algumas sensibilidades Então
eu testei aqui calma eu vou abrir aqui
para vocês eu coloquei sensibilidade
assim eu acho que contém o número esse é
o melhor jogador de free Fire Eu também
vou sair amiga também está em padrão eu
não sei se é o mais correto Ok mas vamos
testar pessoal eu acho que esta
configuração exata para o iPhone com
vocês devem calcular a sensibilidade do
tablet é muito diferente eu tenho que
subir bem o dedo para puxar a capa e não
consigo por isso mesmo é bem complicado
se bem que a muita gente joga tablet
consegue mas eu não consigo parar vou
jogar um recheado aqui para testar
porque eu não quero comprometer a partir
dos meus colegas não é porque eles vão
perder por minha causa técnico
eu posso fazer aqui Um clássico é
clássico mesmo só para testar pessoal o
tem que ter muito bota aqui mas pronto É
disso que eu preciso eu preciso de um
modo para testar a mira a diferença para
o tablet é enorme porque não estava só
com quatro dedos e aqui estou só jogar
com dois eu não sei se a pessoa que joga
com quatro dedos em iPhone muita gente
já me disse que sim até lá na Live
pessoal a dizer que sim meu mas eu não
consigo imaginar alguém jogar assim
impossível é muito complicado então por
enquanto vai com dois dedos mesmo e bora
ver se a minha movimentação é igual ao
do tablet só consigo matar igual a do
tablet pelo menos lá eu consigo matar e
a movimentação também é boa aqui a
movimentação até o parece fácil
tranquilaço olhar virar tá rápido tá
rápido sensor tá muito fluido o jogo tá
em outra está super fluido Agora resta
saber se na hora de matar aquele famoso
capu sobe sobe na cabeça entre pelo
homem que saco da orelha Bora lá pessoal
estamos na bermuda chegamos chegamos à
ilha maléfica Olha só eu vou aqui Ativar
meu token que é que eu tô com ele quando
vocês matam primeiro
é um capacete um colete Talvez uma arma
não sei eu posso ir além daquela cidade
para apanhar catapulta e vamos para o
Observatório Bora lá eu não sei se mais
alguém vai fazer isso mas bora lá tem um
ali que teve a mesma ideia que eu calma
calma calma eu vou já cair aqui agora
solta solta ok pessoal agora lá para o
Observatório aqui eu tenho certeza que
não tem ninguém que eu já vou pegar algo
que já tem uma arma assim de cara OK
então vou aproveitar já para apanhar os
dez anos todos o que é que só só temos
por enquanto armas de dar as Então vou
ficar só tranquilo só na minha aqui
tentar pegar pelo menos umas vai para
sim tem uma arma à distância né
entretanto pessoal também comprei aqui o
pé de que dá gelo porque eu precisava
mesmo para jogar ranqueada porque já meu
já muita gente tinha lá no SEST
ranqueado o perto de dar gelo e está
muito a vantagem você está bem colada a
muita vantagem o'capacete três jamais
Gelo o meu Deus eu tô muito estiloso
Olha só movimentação está um bocadinho
de estranha eu não tava de consigo mexer
o boneco mais rápido ele
é travado mas vai vai vai vai vai eu
agora só quero apanhar alguém para
testar a nossa Mira eu quero testar a
vida eu não sei se tem que aumentar aqui
um pouquinho botão Calma lá e vão baixar
aqui eu tenho que aumentar aqui um pouco
e este botão aqui eu sinto por ti e isso
assim Ah sim vai sim vai Opá eu vou oi
oi Calma que é que tá a tiro assim acha
o rei por trás olha que nem eu vi eu nem
ouvi estamos em classes e como assim
vamos para o Observatório de novo eu já
castigo uma vez correu mal o vento e na
costela mas o ó aqui vai dar certo agora
Calma relaxa relaxa só tem uma capa aqui
já quase quase é parecido foram ali
e como ali olha calma calma calma tem lá
porque é que não chega lá bala viram
viram isso não isso não Mira lá isso não
irá lá eu estou a ser sabotado isso
comigo não funciona nem parece que eu
sou um extra Ok eu quero eu quero esta
aqui a curta distância isso mp40 mesmo é
mais fiz Bora lá pessoal tem um em cima
de mim Calma calma Bora lá tentar subir
o cá posou para um ali viram viram cale
um Ui aqui está aqui olha lá tentar o
capa se
a calma no eixo
e pode esperar a toa eu nem vi o que
estava a fazer
e não morreu Morreu alguém uma tu nem
fui eu eu fiz dando mas nem fui eu
e tem mais gente aqui então tem uma
viram viram viram eu tá subir escada
calma primeiro capa de iPhone foi capa
pessoal primeiro capa eu acho que foi né
E tem uma W tem uma w mas mais gelo Nice
mais pessoal conseguimos a madame ok O
que é que está também a w com esse
telefone OK Mas pelo menos já matamos um
pelo menos já temos a faturar aqui ok
mais um gelo
eu vou bater eu estou bater eu estou
bater donde traz traz traz tem uma calma
Oi oi boa noite estou muito menos
sensibilidade está o rei do qual foi
oi oi na cabeça né Essa foi né Essa foi
né
o meu Deus a sensibilidade aqui é muito
estranho pessoal é muito diferente o
tablet eu vou ter que me habituar muito
meu é bem diferente mesmo é muito
diferente eu preciso fazer eu preciso
puxar muito mais o dentro Eu pensei que
fosse ao contrário eu pensei que não
tava eu precisava de puxar mais mas
aparentemente é que sim preciso prestar
mais vai ser mais complicado ainda então
ok pessoal mas ela está nos dois tá bom
tá bom
e o item 1 ano carro viram ali embaixo
tem um lá
e tem um like Calma eu vou tentar pegar
a mas já ouvi ele entrou ali dentro tem
Calma tem Calma tem calma cuidar que a
guarda te eu vou tentar explodir o
barril Será que ele tá ali
E aí eu falei mas só tem lá embaixo
eu acho não vai meu sinceridade tá muito
estranha o Yuri já morreu
a cui por alguns Sedan
é Amanda que eu tá eu tá aqui ó tenho
aqui uai morreu tá de pijama mas morreu
em podre vai mas ele já vai para casa
vai mas é dormir olha a volta para o
Lobby a volta mas é para o Lobby a jogar
contra a corrente pijama faltar ao
respeito assim não é
oi ui nós temos aqui um drone tem um
drone aqui em cima tem como é que quer
saber Ó já me estamos três Pessoal
espero que morreu duas vezes devidas tá
ótimo tá ótimo Olha alí fraude ai ai
morrendo olha olha eu meter o João
também relaxa é só me diz a cabeça de
fora agora é só vocês a cabeça explodiu
saiu Miley é seu miolo e o que tudo
explodir entrou no ouvido e saiu no olho
Eita cuzaum ângulo de 90 graus de bala
olha para tanto gelo tanto tempo aqui
mas tudo sobre aquele gostinho tiro na
cabeça para que aconteceu olha olha
ninguém brinca contar que faremos agora
hábitos iPhone dos para o Max hahaha eu
tô maluco né eu sei calma calma ele faz
deixa as pessoas assim eu vou para o
Manicômio depois disto ela está nos
quatro pessoal quatro e não são gótico
então tem gelo não sei que não são
buscavam só recarregar aqui na minha
cimafer
e bora lá o próximo Sniper Não é pessoal
é bonita não está aqui acho que aumenta
o meu equipamento né
o grau fiquei com colete todo novo assim
assim vale a pena tem um aqui tem um
aqui calma calma então ali ali ali ali
ah moleque
e olha baixinho porque pobre eu peguei
ontem eu vou morrer por causa disto
Calma calma a minha movimentação está
péssima é só aparecer é só apareceres
E aí eu também tenho uma Eu também tenho
uma vida do ep pizza lá como é que se
diz já eu também tenho uma safado
é bom ter outro gelo já
Tu tá onde tá linda ah não é nada é só
pensa que tinha forem Como assim
e como é que não acertou
e olha olha tá falar tudo assim não
a nossa eu tô começou bugadão
E aí essa foi a pessoal essa foi não
morreu estragou o capacete não estragou
o capacete do homem calma só só não tem
mais a cor pizza de fora e vai ver cama
só até Vou recarregar e tudo eu vou dar
uma puxada um ele mesmo
Ah tá meu tá limpo por outra vez só mais
uma vez só mais uma vez imagem como é
esse piercing esse vídeo ainda desliguei
meu Deus Olha só e acho que estou sem eu
estou sem gelo né Eu estou sem gelo eu
vou meter aqui uma uma dcoe
o ok está destruindo agora com os meus
personagens fictícios enquanto isso vai
levar assim ó na cabeça anda só
o rayquaza
e não morreu fogo é o terceiro que leva
na cara esse é meu como é que não morreu
essa da luminária né Essa Itacaré para o
outro
a este combate taxado fogo finalmente
morreu ainda por cima balas na cabeça
Disney para o homem morreu Ok falta 8
pessoal Faltam 8 Será que vai ser será
que vai ser Bueno iPhone Bora lá estamos
muito perto cuia e mesmo que só se não
for buy eu já cheguei a top 3 não é top
quatro e a chuva aí acho que vai chover
Chaves tira muita vida calma calma calma
vamos colher aqui atrás dessa rocha
é isso por uma boa posição eu acho
Apesar que está embaixo Mas eu aqui
tenho mais ou menos uma posição para ver
onde é que eles estão eu vou subir para
esta Rocha aqui calma aí que considerar
mais em cima o que é perfeito e tem ali
uma caixa Será que tem ali alguém fazer
uma armadilha e eu vou tentar arriscar
só vou tentar arriscar vou já pegar
aquilo puxadão mesmo calma o boa boa tem
um colete quatro mas eu não preciso dele
eu vou esperar aqui os Players eu vou
esperar aqui sim
Oi pode sim traz da Caixa mesmo se vier
alguém já deu tiro
e ali atrás não tem ninguém
e ele também não tem líquido carro
potente né que está toda a gente usa
a Calma Vamos conectar a sexta rochas
que é melhor Ok Isso aí tem um lá tem um
lá
e tem uma
E ai já estou abatido como o rei foi um
tiro rir e foi para ele né A pessoal
fiquei em segundo meu só tá bem que eu
só faltava aquele estávamos quase só
quase quase quatro OK mas este último
teste já deu aqui para testar que eu
preciso eu preciso melhorar muito porque
eu tô muito podre Sniper Ok a
movimentação tá fraca ainda também mas
pelo menos consegui dar um cara ali
coisa que eu não fazia nem sequer no
tablet mas ficamos em segundo sol já
valeu a pena e é isso eu conto com a
vossa ajuda quando o Buzz ajuda comenta
embaixo só como é que eu subi um capa ou
recomendo em algum vídeo de alguém que
tenha ensinado a fazer Ok manda-me para
o Instagram outro ir para o YouTube
mesmo é só partilharem lá porque eu
quero mesmo aprender pessoal E aí Espero
que tenham gostado partilhem com os
vossos amigos que também joga free Fire
para ele rir um pouco talvez mas é isso
pessoal fica bem até a próxima tchau
E aí
[Música]